lamar jackson accurately pointed out
that
the chiefs are the ravens kryptonite
i've seen
on twitter i think michael david smith
of pft noted this along with others
the ravens with lamar jackson are 21-1
against every team in the nfl in the
regular season over the past
two years since lamar jackson became the
starter except the chiefs they're 0-3
against the chiefs
and 0-2 in the postseason we'll we'll
worry about that in january
but i you know when i saw that
i i understand his point but i don't
want him to become resigned to the fact
because superman can never beat
kryptonite it's a given
kryptonite is your thing that will
always beat you
don't declare that anything is your
kryptonite you want to overcome it it
needs to be more like lex luthor who
beats you early and you you come out
or clubber lang or some something that
beats you
that at the end of the day you win when
you label something kryptonite
you're accepting you're never going to
win aren't you no
he's not i don't think that way i think
really
the fact that he's just willing to
accept it that way he's more just going
yeah they got our number
but it doesn't mean he's not going to go
back to the drawing board with the guys
on the team and the coaching staff and
still want another crack at them at some
point
you know in the playoffs but right but
if they're kryptonite i mean superman i
look
here's the thing i i'm not up on the
entire legend of superman from the time
he debuted until now
i don't know if he's ever beaten
kryptonite but the whole premise is
kryptonite is the thing that always gets
you
now look he's always trying to find ways
to
to coexist with kryptonite but
ultimately you want to beat kryptonite
and the way that
it went last night maybe he's right
maybe
maybe we do just need to accept the fact
that this rivalry is never going to be a
rivalry
unless the guy in purple at some point
is going to win one uh
agreed it's not a rivalry right now it
is one-sided i mean
there's no doubt about that and i mean
you know get into it a little bit about
why they are
they're kryptonite per se or whatever
you want to say about that
you know this is i didn't say it nobody
did i you know what i've been saying it
for a while
i i said why didn't you pick the chiefs
last night because i thought that just
with lamar jackson the way he had thrown
the ball the first two weeks the
addition to calais campbell marcus
peters the edginess of them being 0-2
against them the last few years i
thought it'd pull them through
but i was wrong you know and this is
what's amazing about the chiefs i mean
there's a lot of things that jump off
first off patrick mahomes the best
player in football when we end that
discussion that's over
uh there was a really smart smart
quarterback rankings out there this year
that had him as the number one
quarterback
really smart guy people should tune in
to him a little bit then
the other thing that jumps out that i
think i don't figure out who that is
yeah yeah you know exactly who it is
wait
wait but who who out there i i don't pay
attention to anyone else because i got
my hands full dealing with you yeah i
can't imagine that it's a consensus take
that he's not the best quarterback in
football well no
it was it was not that way until uh like
february 3rd of 2020
and then it became oh he is can i have
my vote back for that that other
rankings
so i can do it again but i think here's
the other reason too
you know first off this is something we
don't talk about enough with the kansas
city chiefs mike we really don't because
we look at them as just
high fly and fun football team what
the kansas city chiefs bullied the
baltimore ravens last night
they physically beat them up and we
don't really give
the kansas city chiefs the credit they
deserve in that department and andy reid
for the physicality of his football
teams
all the big bad tennessee titans are
coming to town
whoa derek henry can't get 100 yards oh
the big bad san francisco 49ers and
their defense well they come back and
beat them
now it's the ravens and i think that's
the number one thing
other than the homes that jumps out to
me about their football team
is after that first drive i mean the
intensity on the field
was all on one side and the the team
that was in the
the other team's face like yeah we're
here to hit you
you know we're not going to be bullied
like you do to most people i think that
was one of the number one things that
jumped off to me early in the football
game
and even some of the runs with clyde
edwards elaire and things like that
where
you know i just felt like i needed to
bring that up because we don't talk
about the chiefs we always talk about
high fly and
you know greatest show on turf aspect of
their football team
we need to get a pronunciation check as
well on clyde edwards
l.a it's gone from quite a clyde edwards
hilaire to elaire to
elaine over and over last night i need
to get in touch with my buddy ted cruz
with the kansas city chiefs and find out
exactly what the preferred pronunciation
is but at least they spelled his name
right
on the jersey last night week two they
didn't
so the chief's equipment personnel
getting it right and chris you mentioned
the first drive of the game
i was very concerned for the ravens from
the moment they didn't get a touchdown
the first drive of the game now look
fourth and three do you go for it do you
not go
for it and we are now in an age where we
embrace this idea
of going forward on fourth down we have
seen far more
reckless decisions this year sure then
going forward fourth and three close to
the goal line
but when you start taking field goals
against the chiefs you've already beaten
yourself because they're going to get
their points
so you have to get yours when you can
see that's where
analytics goes out the window because if
you're playing a team
that you know is going to have their 18
to 2 run
at some point oh and they did you better
score while you can
before the storm comes period
so i i at that moment when they put
justin tucker out there for the field
goal no this isn't respectable opening
drive and we get points on the board
you got to get touchdowns against the
chiefs if you're going to have any hope
to weather the 18 to 2 that
is inevitable when you play the chiefs
well it's something you got to always be
aware of
there's no doubt about that now the
ravens are a little different team too
i'm sure they didn't sit there with that
football team they had last night
thinking like
well the chiefs will go on an 18-0 run
on us like right
they're not thinking that way and
especially i think a week after where
they saw the chargers defense where i'm
sure the ravens look at them and go well
we're better than the chargers defense
and i'm not saying they are
but i'm just saying i'm sure they
thought that where they went they slowed
down my homes and company
why couldn't we they had a fighting claw
to score 23 against the chargers
so i think there was probably a little
bit of that aspect
that comes out you're right though it's
a very interesting moment
and then i think after that they kick
the field goal we know kansas city gets
the ball goes right down the field and
we went
whoa that kind of looked easy is that
going to continue like that and of
course
it did continue and then this is where
you know i
love the chiefs and this is the reason i
picked
them to go back to the super bowl and
we'll see where that goes i'm not trying
to like pat myself on the back but i'm
just saying
the other thing that jumps out to me
about them as a football team is they
love that stage last night
they love it they like being the kings
of the super bowl
hill and going hey we're the man oh
you've been getting a lot of chatter
oh oh boom boom boom get down to the
bottom of the hill we're still the kings
of it
and i think they really really love kind
of wearing that badge of honor right now
and they're they're kind of uh you know
what do i want to say just
just loving it i guess that's what i'm
trying to do and and you know what
that's a good point because
i almost feel like the only way you're
going to get the chiefs
is if you catch them napping if they see
you coming
they get ready you got no chance right
the chargers
caught them napping in that wedge
between the build up for the first game
of the season yeah
and all the ravens and patriots are
looming in back-to-back weeks
that was an opportunity to get them when
they weren't necessarily maybe as
focused and see the rest of us saw that
and said maybe maybe the ravens are
ready maybe the ravens are better
yeah and and that plays right into their
hands
because i'm sure the ravens are thinking
yeah okay yeah this we we
this is our time well yeah those teams
you've been beating up on
aren't the chiefs so the chiefs walk in
there with a chip on their shoulder
and a little kryptonite in their pocket
and that's that and and that's that's
look that's part of the the human
dynamics that fuel the sport
you've got to get everyone who's on the
field feeling
that way and and being motivated and
determined and not complacent that's the
biggest
challenge for a defending super bowl
champion is to avoid complacency so
right out of the gates you go 2-0 and
everybody's saying well maybe the ravens
should be the number one team in the
barrel rankings oh the ravens are going
to take care of the team i was saying
last week yeah yeah well we all we all
fell for it we all ate the cheese
and it ended up it ended up turning the
the chiefs uh in the right direction and
and you know now they got the patriots
and
we'll be talking about that later in the
week but it's going to be the same
dynamic
where you know here comes i mean they
get pat i'm looking at their schedule
it's like yeah they're getting past all
these tough games early
i know you know but again but again the
time to get them
is when they don't have full focus
that's the time to get them
and they brought full focus last night
and we saw what happened full focus
they really did you know first things
steve spagnolo
the the job he did on the defensive side
of the ball
you know they brought the fight to the
baltimore ravens and i think that's what
like is rare
you know baltimore usually is the bully
on the field and they bring the fight
and everybody's like whoa whoa whoa
hold on they're going this way they're
going that way they're pushing us back
they're running this over they're doing
all those things
from the get-go and this is where i
think baltimore's going to have to
readjust their style of play the next
time they play kansas city
but kansas city's the same way i mean
they bring the fight too there's the big
bad just think about the first play of
the game
the big bad baltimore ravens we're gonna
bring it to patrick mahomes and
everything like that
all of a sudden there's three motions
going everywhere and they reverse the
tyree kill
and you go whoa and i'm sure they were
like whoa we wanted to be aggressive but
holy crap there was a lot that went on
there and they're fast it's hard to be
aggressive
when they're just coming at us and brian
griese made up
made a good point during the game too
you know there's no rhyme or
reason for what andy reid does he just
goes right it's third and 15. he's as
easily going to throw a screen as he
could throw a bomb down the field like
we saw that amazing play with mahomes
backpedaling for 20 yards before he
throws it to machole hardman
and i think that is also an issue for
baltimore there
baltimore is very smart they break team
down the right break team's down the
right way
and with andy reid you just have no feel
for what he's gonna go he's just gonna
call plays and keep attacking
and that's where it's like the two
football worlds and the way they have
kind of created themselves
really favor the chiefs and what they
bring to the table in that match up
but you know that's one of the most
basic concepts if you can ever get
coaches to adhere to it
being unpredictable on every snap never
allowing the pre-snap look
to show what it is you're going to do
you've got a formation you can run out
of it you can pass out of it you'll find
out when we do it
this formation they may run they may
pass we'll find out what they're doing
when they do it the longer you can
extend that guessing game the better
chance you have of making the play work
especially when you've got better
players
and the chiefs have better players and
the ravens decided that they were going
to try to blitz patrick mahomes
the past protection held up well here's
mahomes after the game talking about how
well his blockers did
it helps that mahomes also was able to
elude them but the blockers had
something to do with it here's mahomes
on that topic
against the blitz same thing uh first
our first going into our defense
i mean when you're going through
training camp against coach spags you're
getting a heavy heavy dosage of blitzes
from everywhere and so i thought guys
accepted that challenge uh in training
camp and it paid off today i mean we
we might necessarily have seen that
exact blitz but we had seen blitzes
with fire zone pressures and cover zeros
and guys sped up their
sped up their routes bill line gave me
enough time because when they're
bringing extra people they're getting
big and really uh
swelling up and i gave me enough time to
put the ball down field and let these
guys make some plays
he was 15 for 19 for 191 yards and three
touchdowns
against the blitz the ravens blitzed on
45 of the patrick mahomes
dropbacks last night and got zero sacks
remember when the titans said
yeah i'm just not even gonna bother
right to blitz dean p's the retired
defensive coordinator we're not going to
get him so why bother
and and that's when he does those
special things
when you try to get him and he starts
moving around and he jumps in the air
and starts to throw a pass and pulls it
back in
and the the stuff that he does defies
the human eye
it does like what did i just see this
isn't like any quarterback has ever
played
and i'm sure the guys trying to catch
him are feeling the same thing so chris
i ask you why even bother to blitz him i
don't know i
you know again that's where you know we
just kind of talked about it where i
just go baltimore is definitely going to
have to readjust the way they play
patrick mahomes the kansas city chiefs
they can't play the way
baltimore wants to play against the
chiefs they might be able to do it
against the other 30 teams in football
but when it comes to playing the kansas
city chiefs they're going to have to
readjust their formula
yeah he's you you can't fluster him with
the blitz
he's very smart and been given answers
to all the tests right
andy reid has him he's andy reid's a
he's an ex online guy
he understands how to pick up blitzes
how to teach his offensive lineman the
proper
techniques as far as you know passing
things off and doing it that way
and then as we talked about with andy
reid too you can't get a beat on them
so it might be third and eight and the
ravens think oh they're gonna they'll
probably block it up and like protect
them and let them make a throw and then
they send out five eligibles and you go
whoa okay whoa
we blitzed and now we don't have enough
guys to cover them you know or they will
you know block it up and do crazy things
and then of course
like you said mike i mean he does crazy
things
the 49-yard pass to machole hardman at
the end of the second quarter
that was a great creative blitz
the baltimore ravens do this blitz and
coverage all the time
and you remember the play right nicole
harmon runs the out and then the up
right
mahomes does the old super bowl shuffle
like he did last year
just fades back all cool and calm 14 and
15 yards down the field
they have more blitzers than they do
blockers but it doesn't matter
and the coverage can't hold up the blitz
was great
but poor desean elliott he's going on a
12-yard out route
covering nicole hartman and he's going
wait
usually teams have already we've already
sacked the other team's quarterback or
the guy's throwing the ball already what
the hell is going on he takes a little
peek back
and mahomes is still back meddling i
mean so he does things to where defenses
can't even prepare for it because i
guarantee in that secondary
nobody has ever made that type of throw
on them with that type of blitz
to where they were probably like what
the hell we sent seven guys
to blitz and he held the ball for five
seconds still into a 50-yard bomb
and that's where he's just out of this
world special to what you're saying it's
never seen really anything like him you
can't prepare for it no you can't have a
scout team quarterback
because you can't do that right you
there's there's only one guy on the
planet who can do it
and here's the other thing about the
blitz and there was a point where it's
27
20. the ravens tighten it up the chiefs
went for it
fourth and one the ravens held they
drive down and score touchdown all of a
sudden a 27
to 10 game is a 27-20 game and the
chiefs are facing a third and 10 from
the baltimore 39 and what do the ravens
do they try to blitz matthew judon up
the middle put some pressure on mahomes
up the middle
and he just he looks and he sees a whole
lot of green
and he just goes yeah and it's not even
a thought
like i'm not gonna even try to throw it
you have abandoned
the entire short portion of the field
i'm gonna just go run for the first down
extend the drive and that to me
felt like the dagger that was like okay
you took your shot
right you you tried at least you tried
bart simpson dropping the cake into the
trash can gif
but when he converted that third and ten
with his legs
that's when to me the air went out of
the balloon from the standpoint of you
and i hoping to ultimately have been
right
with the ravens winning that was when i
knew that forget it it's
it's still yeah hey it's great you're
down 17 you've narrowed it to
seven right it's the fourth quarter but
you're still facing patrick mahomes
yeah and and he's going to find a way
you're i mean
you're you're right oh i mean it's it's
one of the again i think it's one of
those things there too where it's like
they kind of relish it they're like oh
they came back and think they got a
chance
and eric b enemy cusses them all out and
i think they all like that on the
sideline too
i really do they're weird they're messed
up in the head that way
the kansas city chiefs and it's like
they liked like sly like slowly putting
the dagger in them one more time like
we we should have blown you out before
but now we'll blow you out now
and just end this game and he his read
and recognition skills i think is what
we're talking about there when you sit
taught we talk about his ability to see
the blitz
feel a guy you know unblock coming
you know at his backside or feeling that
there's a rushing lane like you're
explaining
he's amazing and there's not a second of
like wasted time
he saw that like pass rush like you're
saying stuck inside
he sees it he reacts he goes and he
keeps his eyes down the field too so
guys in coverage can't come up and
attack him but like
you know really what what should have
been the final score of this football
game this game should have been like 44
to 10
something like that it really should
have been i mean the chiefs really did
some stupid things
let's not forget that and i think still
we're sitting here going well they won
34-20 and it was convincing
and they left a lot of points and and
stuff on the field still
last night and didn't even play their
best best football
but they always do that they never put
four quarters together it's
always the 18-2 run right and maybe
they'll get two 18 to two runs
but if they ever could do from start to
finish what they're capable of doing the
final score would be 64-3
that's the reality they they do sputter
at times and that's what makes their
performance even more amazing
that that it it's lightning strikes it's
not
a methodical patriot style smothering
like we saw
right when they got to 36 on sunday
against the raiders
it is points in in bunches
and then you're just marveling at what
you just saw as the game continues to
unfold and you're right about the
demeanor of the chiefs they
like and and this is i think part of the
reality
of all those double-digit deficits
coming back
in three postseason games being down 10
points with seven minutes left in the
super bowl you develop
an attitude that it doesn't matter what
you do
it doesn't matter go ahead do whatever
you want to do
whatever you do blitz us we got you
don't blitz us we got you
drop eight guys into coverage like
belichick's probably gonna do on sunday
we got you whatever you do we'll figure
it out and it helps
to now have clyde edwards elaire who can
soften up everything underneath if you
give them everything underneath and just
and force you to come back forward so
patrick mahomes can throw it over you
but yeah
it's and then you've got the mad
scientist and andy reid who
looks like he's he really is a mad
scientist in a lab with his face shield
on
just cooking up whatever he wants to do
and keeping you constantly on your heels
look at that eight different guys had a
catch last night including
eric fisher who got that touchdown that
that pushed it to the final score of 34
to 20.
well it's it's hard to me you can't
match up with everybody
and then when andy reads on his game
with creativity and i think like
like what you just said mike like that
cloud edwards
short passing game what we saw on the
first
really the first two drives of the game
with some of the cool screens and short
passes and
fake screen to the left fake screen to
the right kelsey down the middle
the underhand throw to sherman the
fullback for a touchdown like
if kansas city masters that universe
right there of like
screens short passes wide receiver
screens you don't really see kansas city
throw wide receiver screens right
i mean if you could get them to do
screens like like the
new england can and their prime or you
know even
in new orleans and things like that to
where they could start throwing the ball
behind the line of scrimmage of these
receivers and do that and then you mesh
like you're saying
the down the field throws with this
short
like keep your head spinning attack more
of the like the third and fourth than
one stuff we saw
in the super bowl from the kansas city
chiefs with all the crazy formations to
me
if they add that and that becomes
cohesive with the deep part of their
offense throwing the ball aggressively
they'll be unstoppable you know we won't
be able to stop them because the way
they're orchestrated the way they pass
protect
the talented receiver mahomes and then
that formula on offense
is going to be almost unstoppable i mean
because think of the mindset for the
defense
you're you're locked in you're braced
you're white-knuckled you're ready
to try to stop tyree kill and have
somebody account for sammy watkins and
we've got coverage on travis kelsey and
we feel good about this
all right chiefs give it to us bring it
we're ready we're ready
and then they do a little receiver
screen or they hand it off to clyde
edwards elaire
retiree kill goes in motion and you're
getting gash
at a time when you're you're trying to
keep them from running by you
you haven't accounted for the fact that
they're going to run through you yeah i
i know that's exactly it and
this is the attitude that edward zelaire
has brought to the football team i mean
how many
you know there's a few times last night
he smashed it up in there the ravens
couldn't even get him to the ground
he breaks a tackle gets a few more yards
that way
i mean he's given their offense a little
bit of an attitude
he really has he's given them a
toughness element and i think that's
where it's really special so
you talk about all the weapons they have
and that and then now the little
toughness element the screen game
element
wow and then if the defense continues
because we haven't even talked about the
defense yet
and the defense was phenomenal stopping
the offense that we thought was
unstoppable through two weeks and the
player that we thought was unstoppable
and had it all
i mean they just have so many playmakers
that love the big lights
they have creative coaching and it just
seems like
they're really enjoying being super bowl
champ still
and defending their title and not not
coming off that hill
and they kept lamar jackson and the
ravens from getting it going early and
matching them points for points here's
lamar jackson after the game talking
about the ravens slow start offensively
well i'll say second half like
just like i say always like we always
start cranking up at the wrong time we
gotta come in and
finish how we start like we always go
opposite i guess against them for some
reason
we just got to tighten up and play
better that's all
yeah i mean look they they found
themselves down 17
for the second straight year against the
chiefs and it's you can't
turn it on once you're down 17. you've
got to keep it close so as they are
scoring their points
you've got to be scoring your points
that's back to our original point
don't settle for a field goal on the
opening drive of the game because the
storm eventually is coming and
defensively that really was the surprise
last night to see lamar jackson with all
the talk about the improved passing
for him to be held at 97 passing yards
and he never could really get anything
going he he look he's going to get his
rushing yards because when
he puts the the pedal to the metal there
are few people who can come close to
catching him
but when you can't compliment that with
the throws
you're not going to have the kind of
offense necessary
to outscore the chiefs you can go 21-1
against the rest of the league in the
regular season right but you're going to
lose to the chiefs every time you come
up against them
yeah well that's right well the chiefs
have you know some interesting dynamics
on that side of the ball
that really helped them match up with
the ravens for you know first off we've
talked about spags right spags is
creative
he does outside the box thinking he
doesn't care that
oh this defense has never been run in
the history of football
it needs to be run this week against the
ravens to stop them
or whatever so that's where he's awesome
and then
you know again i think it goes back to a
little bit of the like the big bad dude
thing
we started off the show with the chiefs
got some big bad dudes in the middle of
that defense
they liked the fight with baltimore last
night you know chris jones nandi
passing on frank clark they like getting
dirty and then they got two linebackers
in the middle and hitchens and wilson
who are also like that and can run
sideline to sideline
and i think the thing that concerned me
the most or maybe you like the most if
you're the chiefs and i think what
concerns you the ravens is
okay yeah the bread and butter run plays
don't work we can't get that going
the chiefs lock them up in the pass game
locked them
up i mean the lack of wide receiver
involvement of the baltimore ravens
has to be concerning for their football
team it does
oh man the run didn't work well we
couldn't really get mark andrews going
who the hell else is there
i mean hollywood we saw a few shots and
to me that's going to be one of the big
questions about the ravens going forward
mike
we talked earlier about the difficulty
preparing for the ravens because you
don't have access to a patrick mahomes
on your scout team
i think this helps the chiefs defense
that these players in practice
go against that offense right whether
they go ones on ones or whether you're
on the
the you know the backup defense whenever
you're out there on the field
whoever is against the starting offense
is seeing better talent
than they will ever see in a game
and that's how you make your defense
better you're right you put them through
the kind of pressure in practice they're
never going to see
in a game that counts yeah that that's
what good teams do
i mean it goes back to like what my home
said yeah we're used to baltimore ravens
blitzes because spagnola blitzes us all
the time and does crazy crap
so we're not flustered but a team does
it to us and you're right i think that's
a very
valid valid point their defense sees
super freaks
every day in practice so they get out
there with a hollywood brown they're
like oh
yeah you're fast but you're like the
third fastest receiver on our team
so that's where it is it's unbelievable
and the way they covered them up and
made the passing game just
choppy at best for the baltimore ravens
and really not getting anybody involved
in that
very very impressive you know and then
you know tyrone matthew
thornhill on the back end some of those
guys they cover a little bit better
i hope that legeria sneeze didn't get
hurt because he's a really good corner i
know they said he hurt his collarbone
but i was just really impressed with the
secondary
of kansas city 2 to get in the face of
those ravens receivers and
basically make them a non-existent point
in the game last night
but there are issues for the ravens that
are independent
of the struggles against the chiefs that
may be the kryptonite right
here's the reality the ravens can't
start slow
they have to be ahead they are 0 and 10
after trailing at the half 0-6 with
lamar jackson as the starter oh and 10
since 2018
lamar became the starter during the 2018
season
when they lead at the half they
are 20-0 yeah under lamar jackson so
yeah it's and and there are different
ways you can react to that but the
bottom line is there's enough data out
there that it's a trend
that either needs to be reversed or it
needs to be understood you need to
understand
we can't fall behind we can't settle for
a field goal on the opening drive of the
game
we have to go for the touchdown this
isn't analytics this is we're playing
the chiefs and we can't afford to fall
behind we can't go into the locker room
behind
or it makes it even harder to overcome
that that little
that little chunk of green is it green
is kryptonite green
yeah i think it seems like whatever it
is i felt like whatever it's red the old
one
tonight's red well it's red it's red
yeah it's it's it's actually red and it
has a number two it's one in five is on
there okay it's a special edition
kryptonite but uh i mean i think that's
a real thing with the ravens i do
and i think it's gonna be you know we're
gonna continue to talk about it until
they shut us up you know it's a little
bit like oh yeah lamar jackson
you know winning a playoff game we know
that's going to be a thing well i think
before we even get there it's going to
be
can lamar jackson and the passing game
of the ravens win a football game for
them when they can't bully
and overpower people in the run game
that's still gonna be and
through two weeks i thought it's
trending towards i think so
but of course last night it's making me
doubt that once again the ravens though
to that stat you talked about
yeah when they go in at half and they're
leading what is that
you know that what's that allow them to
do it allows them to continue to be
balanced on the offensive side of the
ball right they can still run and be
patient with that
take some shots and then the biggest
thing too is it lets their defense just
be more multiple
oh we're on the lead you have to throw
the ball more
here comes more wink martindale crazy
blitzes and coverages
and it really just plays right into
their hands
let's put a pin in the discussion just
for a minute or two we're going to
continue to talk about the game but you
talked earlier about
demeanor of the chiefs what was the
demeanor of lamar jackson
on that drive when they're down 34-20
and they're trying to cut it again to
seven and you could see the frustration
yeah you could sense it right he was
upset right very different
than that vibe you get from patrick
mahomes and that's the area where the
ravens need to work and maybe they just
need to have one of these comebacks that
works
yeah to get to the point where they've
got that same vibe right that we can do
this but i think
as you look at the overall development
of lamar jackson one of the best
quarterbacks in football
you've got to find a way to erase a
deficit
in the fourth quarter have things go
well command the offense
get down the field score points get the
ball back get the win
and then maybe you start developing that
same confidence that just
emanates from every pour of patrick
mahomes body
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports